[Musique]
maître on peut faire une pause un peu
là quel enfer ça va pas la tête
tu es fou de le déranger comme ça tu
sais qui
c'est est probablement on est là le seul
artiste encore vivant sur cette
planète la caméra énorme ou gigantesque
mote il y a une chose je déteste encore
plus que les enfants c'est les dessins
de les enfants je peux pas les supporter
c'est moi un plus vieux un vieux vous
oui très vieux très chaise roulante
alors voilà ça commence en
[Musique]
enfer
inadmible s'il vous plaît je vous
entends pas ce moment même il y a une
plie des chi Mor
là c'est un
[Musique]
lit je voulais pas vous décourager vous
avez l'air tout excité par le projet
mais entre nous une boulangère qui veut
faire un documentaire sur un
[Musique]
peintre